please please welcome to the stage
mister
haunts him everybody
thank you guys for coming out tonight
[Applause]
uh my name is hans kim and uh i
am from new york as well uh it's good to
be here in the
austin area you know i love the vibes
here it's like a libertarian conference
is going on
constantly with joe rogan here
just brought all the angry dudes here
that yell at each other
but uh the firehouse hostel love it here
i think this
place was built around the bar the bar
is way cooler and bigger than everything
else here
it's [ __ ] crazy uh i guess the
firemen
wanted to get drunk before they went out
and saved people's cats and stuff
but yeah i love love texas
love love you guys because i'm from
south korea so i'm a southerner as well
there's only two things i like shooting
comedies in k-pop southerners
love the southerners i love a good old
redneck because the redneck can survive
in any wilderness situation you put them
in except a situation where everyone has
equal rights
[Applause]
with an alligator why can't we live in a
cul-de-sac with a minority
[Applause]
figure it out
have you tried smiling you know
i think the confederate flag is a little
funny i feel like the confederate fly
would be like if a man went up to his
wife and was like hey honey remember
that time we got into that huge argument
and i tried to divorce you
yeah i'm pretty proud of that time
it represents who i am as a person
that's why i got a divorce papers
tattooed on my chest
but uh yeah i do love uh being american
uh my asian friends make fun of me
because i like to eat generous chicken
like hans chicken just a shitty
americanized version of something
authentically
asian i'm like yeah but so am i
my favorite movie is rush hour three
i love being asian or as i know this
country chinese
i'm from a province in china called
south korea
it's right next to japan province
whenever someone's racist to me i'm like
oh you hate respectful people who meet
to themselves
okay good luck finding an affordable car
make all of that
one of my friends was like dude you got
such an asian smile
i was like oh thanks now i get to think
about how i'm physically different from
everyone around me
every time i feel happiness
a lot of people who are racist don't
even realize that they're racist this
one guy comes up to me and he's like
tokyo we took away all this sale
i was like dude you're such a racist
just because i
look like this doesn't mean i speak your
ching chong language
don't be racist and the post office is
right there
can i say the post office
but yeah i mean a lot of people make fun
of asians because we like to eat dogs
which i understand can be very shocking
because in america dogs are treated like
family members
but in asia we treat our family members
like family members
it's this weird little tradition we have
back home of buying an animal
we love our grandma
treat everyone better in asia unless
you're a baby girl which case you throw
you in the river
else retreat really good don't look at
the river
i mean uh asian women they've had it too
good for too long okay
sadly can't calm down
asian women act like they're hotter than
asian men but that doesn't make any
sense because we look exactly the same
i could throw on a wig and be a seven
why are you bragging that you can [ __ ]
white dudes i can [ __ ] white dudes
we can all [ __ ] white dudes it's not
impressive
everyone acts like asian men aren't sexy
but how do you think asian women are
created
me [ __ ] i'm a crucial part of the
sexy process
please stop trying to skip me
if you have sex with me our children
will be very beautiful
half of them the other half will be
great engineers and that's important too
[Music]
a lot of people act like asian men are
small dicks
which even if that was true and it's not
it's pretty big but
it was it's not like we hear that we're
like oh we got small dicks okay we'll go
find a new hobby sorry to bother you
we wouldn't just give up we would start
studying because that's what we do
we learn how to use it like a sewing
machine
this orgasm brought to you by panasonic
playstation
[Applause]
we got the machines on our side okay you
got to come try our vibrators
make the best ones too love uh
love dating i'm single right now i've
yet to meet my soul mate i'm beginning
to think maybe a terror fall she needs
to get out more
she seems like a loser
i think i can do better
i know what i look like but i'm not that
into anime okay
which is unfortunate because the only
women who are sexually attracted to me
are
pretty into anime i forgot i have
resting anime face
i'm on
and then i have sex with an anime girl
which is where you
pass out holy hands
uh but yeah i mean a lot of the ladies
that i date like to call me a premature
ejaculator i mean
how ridiculous is that you're hurting my
feelings lady you know it's like
premature into who
i came right at the perfect time when i
felt amazing
i think it's maturity to know how to
please yourself
now i'm coming like oh my lady it seems
like i have came upon your chest
tuna top of the morning
toast mature orgasm
but uh i do love the ladies uh
i think they are the sexiest gender in
the human race definitely in the top 52.
i don't think i could ever have sex with
a dude i've never looked at a beautiful
woman and been like wow she's gorgeous
but is there a version of her that's
bigger and hairier and has less kindness
i want to put that inside me
no thank you i'll stick to the beautiful
kind people
please believe me my dad doesn't
i have a sapiosexual that means i'm
looking for a girlfriend who is
intellectually
stimulated by the mental exercise of
finding me attractive
like a woman is into puzzles really
difficult ones
my friends are like dude we're so lucky
we're not gay can you imagine that most
of the gender we were attracted to
wasn't attracted to us back
and i was like whoa can't even imagine
they must cry a lot
my friends are like uh dude you need to
learn how to talk to women
maybe or maybe women should learn to
listen to hans
why don't you want to hear about the
federal reserve
it's so intricate we're at a party come
on
[Music]
this one lady was like hey did you know
that because my vagina can make a baby
come out of it my vagina is technically
a 3d printer
i was like actually lady your womb is a
3d printer your vagina is the tray
[Laughter]
it only prints one thing with lots of
errors
it takes nine months to print
and the whole time is printing is
complaining
needless to say i did not say any trades
that night
but i love dating you know uh i think
women are very sexually attractive
and of course it's pretty cool but it's
pretty difficult for me because 99 of my
sex career was so low
and now i have to have an orgasm while
someone's fogging up my glasses okay
i know what my name is you don't have to
keep saying it
where's my office chair i'm going to
come to my office
at this point but
i think it's funny that uh tanner is a
white person's name
i mean tanner then what
should be like hey this is my mexican
friend tanner my black friend tanist
i'm not a racist okay
i'm asian could i be impossible
i don't even see race i don't even see
race okay
i only smell
but i it the whites the whites are great
you gotta respect the military oh my god
the military they have
great culture they can't sleep on their
military
but i think having white pride is done
incorrectly okay
people with white pride are always into
like the nazis or the confederate flag
they're never into building a castle or
yodling
nazi's a confederate flag is not white
pride that's racism
okay you don't have to be white to be
racist i can eat the juice too
i saw a dude on an airplane reading a
book in arabic which kind of freaked me
out
but then i saw him fold the corner of
the page and put the book away and i was
like oh thank god he's got future plans
uh not a racist i uh
my favorite marvel movie is the black
panther movie because it gave black
children a hero they could finally look
up to
yeah yeah and not just someone like will
smith
or samuel jackson or frederick douglass
or malcolm x or martin luther king jr
nelson mandela
jimi hendrix obama oprah tupac baby
now there's a fake person that dresses
like a cat
when are they gonna come out with the
yellow superhero the yellow panda
dating you know i used to date this
woman who was really into yoga
and choke sex and i was like do you
enjoy breathing or not
i don't understand why they say in
prison don't drop the soap it should be
don't pick up the soap
you can drop as much stuff as you want
because i'm bending over where they
really get you
even if you don't drop the soap you're
still going to get raped you're just
going to really clean hands while it
happens
who are these rapists like man i want to
get that kid but he never drops a soap
because you have a butthole now
rapists don't like that they're
go-getters they don't take no for an
uh answer yeah i mean uh i saw a sign in
my neighborhood that said
20 miles per hour when children are
present but how fast do i drive if the
children are dwelling in the past
uh it's pretty difficult for me to ride
in the car pooling being single
i feel like the carpool lane is like
society saying hey you know how you're
lonely
yeah do it for longer you loser
watch people with friends whizzing by
you
all right that's been my time thank you
guys very much